el león del panshir ese era el apodo de
amaichá masoud un señor de la guerra y
muyaidín afgano hace 20 años perdió la
vida en un atentado suicida perpetrado
por al qaeda cuando un supuesto
periodista hizo estallar una bomba que
llevaba en el interior de su cámara
durante una entrevista al funeral fueron
cientos de miles de personas
estamos muy tristes porque no está aquí
lo sentimos porque no está con nosotros
hoy es un día de luto
masoud sirvió como líder militar y
político del frente islámico unido se
convirtió en una de las figuras
centrales en la resistencia contra la
ocupación soviética entre 1979 y 1989 y
fue el principal comandante de oposición
contra el régimen talibán entre 1996 y
2001 sus seguidores lo llaman amir shah
ya hit que significa nuestro amado
comandante martín a decidimos osos y
estamos mi mandante atrás de extractadas
nuestro objetivo actual es liberar todas
las zonas perdidas y obligar a los
talibanes a sentarse a negociar y
aceptar el hecho de que la nación afgana
debe tener derecho a participar en la
decisión de su destino y que debe ser la
nación la que decide su destino
en mayo de 2012 el parlamento declaró el
día 9 de septiembre de cada año como día
de los mártires y de hamás a masoud y
también fue declarado héroe nacional por
el presidente hamid karzai ante su
ausencia a su hijo amat masoud tomó la
batuta
lo que estamos defendiendo ahora es para
todo el país es para la soberanía es
para la paz es para las personas es para
la inclusión y la tolerancia y la
aceptación y la moderación es por todos
estos valores es por nuestra bandera y
por las creencias que tenemos por este
país link del visado por descanso ahora
es él quien encabeza la resistencia de
panshir tras la retoma del poder de los
talibanes en afganistán aunque ellos ya
han proclamado su conquista